we're we're on our way to disney world
disney world what are we going to do
their gumbo we're gonna go to Dumbo ride
we just got to the toronto airport and
i'm super excited because i didn't have
to take off my shoes again custom
security cuz i got the five toe shoes
what do you do and we're a little
worried because we're taking a nine
o'clock flight out which is this guy's
bedtime so we're going to arrive at
midnight run the car and then get to our
Airbnb place at maybe one in the morning
or so mean and I didn't sleep that well
last night so we're gonna go buy
something so I'm gonna go to Kim
Morton's if I don't need to get Nina
wants an extra large if your life yeah a
large large french Villa Cucina it's
like 630 almost seven o'clock at night
now Plus that sandwich me and hayden
wants a bagel bagel yeah are you wiping
your eyes here you are you tired already
know okay well I'm gonna get to see mr.
yeah yeah that's good I'm gonna get some
food and then get on the plane disney
world here we come okay well we made it
on the plane
it's already Hayden's bedtime so you're
staying up extra late but Hayden's got
his iPad playing field runners and I'm
going to take off in about 40 minutes 30
minutes and make her way to Florida yes
not
it is may be hating will map on the
point what do you think yes yeah you're
gonna have a good nap I don't think so
ok so it's midnight we just arrived we
lend it a little bit early but up a
plane we had no checked baggage so we
got here quick Hayden has not slept at
all are you tired no I'm tired we are at
the budget waiting to get our car
supposed to be fast break but it's
taking forever we got our car soon they
can get on the road so it's almost two
in the morning we finally got here place
is amazing you can see my eyes I'm
burning out I just put eight in the bed
I'm gonna get changed go to bed and get
ready to start the day fresh tomorrow
super excited it's day one we had a
little bit of sleep Hayden's got a lot
of excitement we went we went to sleep
at around two and woke up at nine 88888
we haven't figured out how to get Wi-Fi
in our place which is the most important
part we need y divided people so I want
to give you a tour of our plan right ok
so here's this is our Airbnb place that
we pull in to forgive you the big tour
so we walk in we have a dining room here
we have a Hayden this is our living room
so Anna Nina hmm hello it's pretty huge
we have our kitchen full-on kitchen so
we can make whatever we want we've got a
fridge with the water nice because
we've got pantry huge closet master
bedroom all of the bedrooms ostriches
are two twin beds we put these ones
together yes and then we have our
ensuite bathroom we have our closet
master closet Nina has already organized
all of our stuff Nikki wants to be in
the video
and we've got Hayden's room and your hat
Hayden gets his own bathroom pretty
sweet and we have another bedroom with
two more twin beds or single beds that's
for you to and huge closets in every
room so tons of space if we were to stay
on Disney properties that the the hotels
are ghetto unless you're spending tons
and tons of money this place is super
close we rented a car and it's going to
cost us what's it gonna cost 99 a pretty
good deal for all of this space anyway
good so we're gonna go get some food
we're gonna go find some Wi-Fi today is
our shopping day and get acclimated and
bar food and stuff that we can make for
the week I say we but it's not really we
me we're gonna go have some fun bye bye
so we went to dennys and the lineup was
out the door so we ended up pulling into
wendy's and wendy's we discovered
doesn't have a breakfast menu so we are
having cheeseburgers baconators french
fries but for breakfast this one this is
totally dead because they don't have a
breakfast menu what about this many
people the other thing is I'm not we got
to get used to the American sizes
this this is a medium Hayden's got some
fun toy we're here mostly for food and
to get Wi-Fi so we can plan out Nina's
shopping day so we're doing so so far a
terrible experience at the wendys we are
going to be throwing away most of what
we got here which is super bland and
gross the internet is not working which
is the main reason why we came so we're
going to find some somewhere else I feel
gross from eating that burger and I'm
going to find something maybe some
fruits or a little healthier that also
has Wi-Fi Sweden tonight not a great
start but name is in a good mood oh yeah
Nina got a haircut look at that yes oh
and he didn't want to show his new toy
that's really the best thing that we got
at Wendy's here lyst havens toy that
he's excited about okay have to find
some other place and look at the huge
sign on Wendy's quality is our recipe
that's total crap quality is not the
recipe for this Wendy's we are never
coming to this one these again and maybe
not another American Wendy's again we
just got out of the public's i'm not
sure what we got Wi-Fi I don't bill for
the Wi-Fi is great but ah it is all
excited about the Wi-Fi we got apples
celery sticks
carrots this is the crazy part you go to
most Canadian supermarkets the first
thing you walk into is the produce
fruits and vegetables here it's all the
way at the back on the left i'm walking
like where are the vegetables as soon as
you walk gain all your scene is pop and
the retos and a whole bunch of crap and
you have to walk all the way through the
store to the end to the left to find the
fresh produce anyway going on a little
bit of a rent we ought to eat healthier
people american supermarkets got to get
your stuff together but i'm happy that
there's Wi-Fi so maybe we'll connect
nina and hayden are practicing their
ability to walk in a straight line i am
chopping down on my celery sticks and we
are at this humongous outlet mall that
we're going to go try to find some stuff
for Nina it was her birthday not so long
ago and I promised her a shopping trip
in Florida so this is for her you write
another mall Nina's doing more shopping
this time we're going to macy's and then
this mega mall that just keeps on going
and we'll see if Nina will buy something
here to the journey continues it's
lunchtime we were all set to go to
chipotle like
it's prolly and then we're heading to
the washroom who's this guy
and they handed out these falafel
samples that were amazing so we decided
we'd have lunch here that's Nina and
this is what you hear I don't with the
cilantro sauce this one is cilantro
sauce so we're gonna eat try it
too big
and healthier than our breakfast so
we're driving here and we just found the
car ahead of us House believe as a
bumper sticker or two sticker on the
window believe we're happy Nina found it
peace peace from Nina and from Hayden
Hayden got a new toothbrush what's the
new toothbrush the quarter lightsabers
all right we made it back to our condo
and we made a couple other pit stops I
noticed as I walked in so this is the
front door and on the side this is
notice from Florida International
College I don't know that's about but
I'm luck look at their slogan bully
achieve succeed yeah we're seeing a lot
of belief today here's Hayden you got a
special toothbrush Darth Vader
lightsaber good okay we went grocery
shopping bought some food for the week
mostly healthy stuff but some mix of
stuff we got a we got some beer rolling
rock and I'd never heard of but anyway
but since we have a kitchen we can make
our own food for the week which is
exciting Nina also bought some stuff
it's a huge right it's huge you know
what's our shorts let's see put them up
against ooh looking good yum Oh new this
is the primer for your face before you
passed
that's a very smooth I tried it at the
store and then I got a foundation Larson
foundation always wanna try one so yeah
cheering mineral finishing powder that's
after you have everything on and then
you just use this Nina is a little sad
that she hasn't found more clothes I was
the only one who bought nothing for
himself so we'll see if that changes I
just hope the new doesn't secretly want
to try all those makeup products on me
when did we do that last time okay uh
we're gonna we're gonna what were you
think we're gonna cook we're gonna cook
clean up and rest and then tomorrow
morning wake up and go to magic kingdom
by I South improvement books are like
Fitness books they never work on their
own what you need is a trainer that's
Evan get the newsletter
you